have you worked there before on anything
I've worked there on SNL which they have
a Lauren Michaels produced SNL it's ever
the same set and everything they play
the same kind of music and they have
like sketch comedy from
um
you know these people who kind of look
like a cross between Fred armerson and
Martin Short they all look a little bit
like old SNL creatures yeah teachers
yeah and um then they have like the star
of the week and they'll do sketches that
are like all comedy based on it's in
Korean yeah it's all in Korean and you
can speak it and I can speak it a little
bit yeah yeah there's enough to do a
little bit of Comedy so I did a set on
there and they uh they subtitled mine
and then every time people were supposed
to laugh they highlighted it so they
would know to laugh wow it was really
cute and there's a live audience and
everything the live audience that's
don't you want to do that you would be
great they would never ask me they would
love you how would I don't even know how
to do it well if you ever go over there
what I was I happened to be over there
and then you know we had been talking
and so yeah I think there'll be more
crossover now that there's more of um
you know especially because also Netflix
is making all that Korean content so now
they won't want to have it's very very
fashionable to be korean-american too
when you go over there really you're
like very much excited people are very
excited to try their English that's
interesting did you not feel that way
when you went to Korea a while ago no
I felt like it was the opposite of that
it's changed it has really changed
because I shot a you know a K-pop video
so great and I but what I realized there
there's the there's no Union or whatever
we we worked 16 hours with no breaks
yeah it's that's that's it I danced for
so many hours that's what makes a
difference between what we do here yeah
where whereas there I think I think
they'll probably have more of a sense of
needing to do that 16 hours of that yeah
yeah all right yeah it was hard it was
so hard yeah like I watched the
blackpink documentary yeah and those
girls what they went through to even be
chosen so it's insane like they are
working to the ground these girls
they're so talented black panther I'm
sorry I'm not blackpink is a pop pop
girl girl group how many times except
for Lisa actually at least that's high
yeah oh there's one okay yeah Foreigner
in it and um it's a girl group they have
albums out yeah right and the
documentary is about them trying out for
the band know how they came to be how
they came to be they're created but they
also I mean they still work hard and
they're um you know they're doing acting
work too and they're doing
um so one of them is so beautiful yeah I
think Rose is it jisu or Rose is in a K
drama maybe one or the other is in a
k-drama Jenny is on the idol
she's so beautiful she's so good and
they also have their own sort of solo
careers too they're like BTS wow so
they're killing it they're so their best
is the music good so good it is it's fun
I love it it's pop it's fun I love the
music because I feel like you were
always like a kind of a Velvet
Underground girl or no I like I like pop
too yeah yeah oh you do I love this I
love K-pop and pop music like I think
well it's all it's just so so
um it's also full of hooks and you know
I just I love music like that yeah so
good I like The Velvet Underground too
yeah but I mean you know I'll be honest
when I'm on the road sometimes I'll put
on some Taylor Swift yeah you love you
love Demi Lovato I love Demi Lovato
yeah I worked with her I like her she's
great I like Sia yeah Taylor's new album
is great so yeah no I listen to it she's
great yeah yeah she's wonderful you know
her I've never met her oh I know Sia
yeah I love Sia she's great yeah but
yeah as I get older well I think for me
it's like when I was younger I was like
it's gonna be only be you know what I
mean fugazi
yeah yeah but only like DC bands or
velvet underground or like early 70s
punk like I like The Clash right but pop
sucks [__] Madonna I was like that guy
but now bro check it out dude
check check out who I like
The Grateful Dead I [__] love now
what
I like them too I hate it I hated them I
would have killed Jerry Garcia with my
hands that's because you watch a
documentary they're so good oh the
documentary got me I was at my a meeting
right I was sitting around with a bunch
of comics some hipster ones you know
ones with the funny shoes you know I
mean you know they always wear the the
more reality shoes futuristic like
leather no leathery anyway
English you know and they they sit weird
and they're you know I mean and they're
like they seem like Roxy Music guys that
like cool you know yeah and then they
were like talking about the dad yeah
they [__] suck man [__] they're so
good yeah yeah who who who who does a
jam in G major for 45 [__] minutes
what's the time right two minute songs
baby it's like no watch the documentary
yeah
so I reluctantly watched it and I S one
night I burned through it and then all
of a sudden I started downloading
live albums and stuff and now I listen
to it at night incredible and they're
[__] so good it's a good change is
what you're saying yes we can always
change a documentary that I love that
she told me about is a meet me in the
bathroom oh I haven't seen that yet it
was so good especially if you're I I
just feel nostalgic for that very
specific time yeah well Banks was in it
The Strokes yeah I like all those all
those bands too yeah yeah so that I
would I have to see that yeah and like a
Karen knows in it